[Music]
sixty-six seconds of goddamn logos a
brisk Walker will always catch up to
someone running for their life cliche
Fiat shot him in the head none of this
would happen the fact that the movie
thinks this many people would ever come
to a public talk titled the
interpretation of symbols professor of
religious symbology is a title that
doesn't exist at Harvard University or
anywhere else in the world symbols are a
language that can help us understand our
past some symbols can be written
together to represent words and those
collections of symbols can be combined
with other collections to form sentences
so in other words words or language that
can help us understand our past Robert
Langdon professor of wingding ology
professor Langdon felt the need to Ken
Burns this photo
even though zooming out doesn't reveal
anything that would lead these students
to think this was a photo of anything
but the KKK in English place that's
racist how in the hell did this shot of
Tom King Hanks in front of a giant Nazi
flag not ever become a meme our most
beloved American actor in front of a
symbol of racism and genocide Jesus I
know I wasn't put on this earth to
expose this imagery but kind of feels
like I was how do we write our own
histories personally or culturally the
professor doesn't realize that he is
auto-scrolling through the rest of his
presentation tonight this will be our
quest if you look into your chairs you
will each find an envelope now hiring
too many extras for overcrowded bar
scene and major motion picture this mob
of people is here to get the autograph
of a symbols professor from Harvard like
he's Tom Hanks or something considering
your expertise and the markings on the
budding clue so over here shows laying
in a photo of a corpse while he's in the
middle of a public book signing that's
not just bad police work that's rude to
the people who waited in line to show
him their pictures of corpses and waited
for over now he waited for over an hour
it was very nice of John Travolta to
donate his favorite hair piece to this
production
Morris Internet's numismatist discount
oh what a lovely day I have found that
nudity almost always enhances religious
experiences
ah I don't want to look at for 400 Alex
goddamn this movie is a Catholic 50
shades of grey me our Father we didn't
agree on much frankly I was surprised
when he contacted me that's an awfully
bad dub for a movie that cost 125
million can we take the stairs being
afraid of elevators when you believe in
an ancient biblical future prediction
code video surveillance in a museum
Assizes cost-prohibitive also ridiculous
also the Louvre has over 1,000 security
officers I don't teach at Harvard but I
do have Google how and why do they pay
that many officers without having money
for cameras just fire some dudes it's
not rocket science the Grand Gallery
this way you've found the body one
character saying what the other
characters in the scene already know
narrations distant cousin the filmmakers
avoid clever character deductions by
just simply having someone interview
them what would you do if you had such
limited time to send a message oh I
don't know recreate a famous Leonardo da
Vinci sketch with my body and leave
cryptic anagrams all over my place of
work what would you do in case you tried
to run we have you on a little leash
professor well I am moving enemy at a
state much also yep you are watching a
movie where a shady agency just bugged a
symbols professor in the name of
international security GPS tracker that
shows toilets quite a leap isn't it
Langdon sums up this entire movie
Jackson Young was my grandfather
apparently it was his dying wish that we
meet because the old man had his
fetishes just like the rest of us should
have walked by a subdued me instead of
assuming Langdon found his tracker and
threw it into the dump truck he assumes
that Langdon jumped out of the window
and into the dump truck I will take a
moment even though they are running from
the cops so he decides to take a moment
and Langdon obliges he's much older than
I remember here's a fun fact all people
are currently older than the memories
you have of the the sentence literally
applies to everyone
also these evil satanic Bible based
villains drew the star on this dude's
chest right-side up instead of the more
traditionally satanic upside down you
did color flashback a child runs things
were apparently remembered or learned
here from my office today several times
he said it wasn't my top life
I ignored him of course because who
believes that kind of worship this is
wrong
yeah see this is wrong the Fibonacci
numbers only makes sense when they're in
order what the fuck is happening right
now
nanogram I'm gonna go ahead and give ten
sins to cover anyone saying something
that the person they're talking to
clearly already knows when it's actually
just being said to explain it to the
viewer Co 9000 don't Frances FBI left
one officer at a crime scene that also
happens to be one of the world's most
famous landmarks looting this painting
didn't trigger an alarm did the museum
turn off all the alarms during this
investigation coz without cameras and I
don't see those 1,000 security guards
that seems like an unwise idea Madonna
of the rocks is not located in the same
room as Mona Lisa also it's more
commonly known as virgin of the rocks--
but frog kitchen Weiser doesn't make for
a very sexy anagram da Vinci himself
da Vinci only refers to where he is from
it would be like people referring to me
as of Nashville most historians call him
Leonardo fleur-de-lis as their crest
they picked one of the most common
symbols to signify their secret society
because the fleur-de-lis is also
associated with French Catholics in
general and is on coats of arms and city
crests and in architecture and paintings
and has royal associations and is on the
flag of Baton Rouge Louisiana and boob
pasties for Mardi Gras this girl driving
like born backwards is laughable Tom
Hanks is the gender swapped franka
potente
aka borns girlfriend your luck combined
with a screenwriter who likes you I
think this flashback is literally
footage from taking julian assange
origins no lie this is a flashback of a
guy reading a book Ron Howard's finest
work yell an earthquake will now help a
Bible Code secret-agent escape jail and
no one in this movie will giggle about
it also Silas played by Paul escaping a
prison after an earthquake do you not
get it this nun leaves the sacred room
because a crazy albino dude and a Jedi
robe basically begs her to we should be
saving this bar for a few minutes a park
filled with drug addicts in the middle
of the night yeah you should be fine
the police don't patrol this excellent
observation American dude but also why
don't they and if they don't why are you
here without backup this guy totally
ripped off his treasure map following
maneuver from Indiana Jones nun watches
Silas break the floor and doesn't ask
him what he's doing tell him to stop or
call the police never occur to you that
could be dangerous no and now we have a
place to think
you paid off a druggie and bought all
his belongings just so you could use
this picnic table as a place to think
the fuck's wrong with the officer at the
car or a hotel bar or motherfucking
bathroom stall any all these options are
better than
50 euros on a needle a candle some drugs
in the goddamn picnic table Jesus
puzzles codes a treasure hunt yep this
is the religious non fun national
treasure you were all clamoring for nice
going America the Templars were all but
exterminated what's not have been very
good Knights to begin with if 99% of
them can be all bitch killed in the same
night right the date was October 13th
1307 of Friday Friday the 13th also haha
also fear of Friday the 13th didn't
really begin until the early 20th
century even though some of the actual
Knights of Templar were arrested on this
day mainstream historians don't
associate it with right at the 13th
superstition nun bashing this prayer
over a dead woman is intended to show
that this guy is even if misguided still
devout whatever I'm not gonna forget
that he straight-up murder this not so
your character development is in vain
1976 76 a year of Independence 1976 was
a year of Independence for Portugal this
movie I like it's characters sees what
it wants to see lot is being spared that
yeah but you're spilling it also that's
why you're spilling I know you Catholics
have trouble telling the difference
sometimes a single wrong entry disables
the system because rich people don't
make mistakes honey I don't even like
history this is the historical biblical
treasure hunting movie equivalent of I'm
too old for this the Rose was a symbol
for the hologram and also Charles Foster
Kane sled and a popular modern college
football game aunt love and that chick
from Titanic and a poison song and cop
notices Rolex on armored car driver and
his suspicious that's a good cop but
then he's immediately dissuaded because
that driver tries to sell him the launch
for a cheap price on the spot so he lets
him go that is a bad cop confessing your
sins the nude man God knows what you're
packing already give us a loincloth or
something a nun killing all died no bad
nun killing albino are you good hearing
man professor I was raised a Catholic
classic avoiding the question critics
there used to keep secrets well there
used to decipher codes that's not as
romantic a way of putting it is what you
just said but it's still way more
accurate you make it sound like a
Pensieve and Harry Potter when it's
really more like the glasses and
national treasure
it's said Vinci's design I know it
anywhere and within 1.5 seconds of
seeing it
never
who knew that much about a creek yes
that's because they don't exist not
looking at the road while driving also
being a truck driver and not Hawking at
the person coming straight toward you
this weird face massage goes on for some
time instead of killing them and sparing
us another two hours of this horse this
asshole just leaps I dunno a Grail
historian absolutely obsessed with
Priory men well that's convenient
English men lives here in France here in
the country you're in right now that's
fucking amazing so you want to keep all
tests close to all calls yes hilarious
though more hilarious when it was Sandra
Bullock doing this bit and demolition
man but still you rural screenwriter
language barriers are hysterical
was a lifelong pagan who was baptized on
his deathbed I'm just gonna toss about
12 more sins on this movie for all the
liberties it takes with church history
one for each of the twelve disciples but
a growing religious turmoil was a
gripping Rome three centuries earlier a
young Jew named Jesus come along oh
you're saying disah's divinity came from
a vote how else did you think the Bible
was put together lady all the humans
watch while it put itself together it's
not semantics Yuri you're interpreting
facts to support your own conclusions
Tom Hanks Ian McKellen and Audrey
tatooine message board the movie SATs
for many Christians putting the literal
chessboard between them during this
argument is a bit on the nose mr. Howard
considering both the Bible and standard
Grail legend celebrate this moment as
the definitive arrival of the holy
prayer the Bible contains no mention of
the Holy Grail I'm starting to severely
doubt this man's credentials as a Grail
historian you're saying the Holy Grail
is a person a woman just go with it
ma'am or we'll be here for three hours
oh wait oh hey Scott dome on the mind
sees what it chooses to see scotoma
refers to partial loss of vision he
might mean pareidolia which refers to
seeing patterns that aren't there which
is what he seems to be guilty of besides
not knowing anything about what he's
been researching his whole life and
these two figures changed position I'm
smelling some serious both right here we
could change all of their positions to
make the last supper look like the last
orgy but we don't because that would be
looking stupid but I bet some of your
gonna do it anyway and I can't wait to
see it listen to this it's from the
Gospel according to Philip alternative
sunday-school the movie the witches
it's instructed the clergy on how to
locate torture and kill this movie's
original title was literally three hours
of exposition inside the Keystone no
beer map I'm at lead us to the hologram
I'm sorry didn't you just spend like the
last 20 minutes explaining the girl was
a person a blood descendent of Christ so
how can a map in a Keystone from
centuries ago actually lead anyone to a
living breathing human being with the
free will to go wherever he or she
chooses
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba apparently the riddle
song is the theme for Harry Potter I
realize you're trying to evade the cops
but there's an argument to be made that
using paved roads even well possibly
expected by the cops is still a faster
getaway option than these roller coaster
woods you've chosen we are in the middle
of a wall on one that has been going on
forever
actually 2000 years give or take a
couple hundred what if the world
discovers of the greatest story ever
told is actually alive then the world
will probably continue just as it is
because what was it the mind sees what
it chooses to see oh oh that's right
modern scholars agree Jesus was likely
on the cross for about six hours twice
the length of this movie and without
ever having been crucified I can tell
you without question this movie is much
more excruciating even at half the time
yeah doesn't forgive matters actually he
does sorry
once the sarcophagus is destroyed DNA
testing will be impossible there is no
way to prove a living bloodline there's
also no way to prove whatever body in
the sarcophagus is actually Mary
Magdalene a guardian of the Holy Grail
it sounds so stupid so P would be
excellent at cinemasins I means my
innate Robert like a girl again just
with no gift at the end it's obvious
Sophia is the descendant of Jesus this
movie is searching for I'm not sure why
the movie tries to act like it could be
anyone else but for three hours it sure
does
I'm sorry shit bout to know cuz day wait
he's still wearing the Opus Dei pin why
does he think this is some sort of
secret movie acts like they just pulled
off some Ocean's eleven move when they
just got out of the complain before the
cops showed up my what a lovely fake ass
palace you have when he was a boy young
Robert having to a well just like Bruce
Wayne and baby Jessica also Robert has
the same weaknesses as the aliens from
science it's 1185 modern London just
sprang up right around it does everyone
have to explain everything all the time
it's like being followed by a
personified Wikipedia in that some
information might be true but there's no
way to know for sure those
nights with their legs crossed means
they've been to the Holy Land oh I
thought it meant they had to go to the
bathroom you don't have a close shot yes
I do dunk dunk dong I'm totally
surprised by that non surprise Ron
Howard has been hinting at every time
this Remy dude has been on screen since
the movie began shocked I tell you Wow
you got me movie punching old people
sorry
deus ex machina like maybe for real this
time
dear God make me a bird so I can fly far
far far away from here the nuns don't
scatter
I love how Paul Bettany albino assassin
just casually wears a friars robe
everywhere he goes like that won't
arouse any weird looks or suspicion this
movie has about 14 surprise reveals too
many hey Pope his first initial how did
I miss that because the words a pope
make absolute and perfect sense on their
own without deeper meaning or further
interpretation these attacks movie about
ciphers and riddles gets overshadowed
near the end by a scooby-doo esque Hey
look footprints moment you sir have been
a ghost allmovie.com be exposed
mankind can finally set free there are
over 1 billion Catholics in the world
which means about 6 billion people in
the world aren't Catholic in fact about
2/3 of mankind isn't even Christian so
calm down Appl a that spells asshole
also in what movie an apple is not a
goddamn or an apple is a fruit and even
if you were to describe its shape you
would not use the word or you use the
words vaguely roundish with both the top
and bottom Buttle we're in the bottom
but hole is often surrounded by foreign
knuckle peaks and the top butt hole
almost universally has a stem growing
out of it not a king orbit thank you
oh really obvious here of Christ really
if this whole thing collapses in a
flying saucer takes off from underneath
I swear to god I'm gonna lose my son
here didn't want you to help guard the
secret of the Holy Grail Sofie you are
the secret you are the heir surprise
unless you're not stupid
welcome home child we don't believe your
ancestor Jesus was divine but we do
believe in treating you like you were
divine for some reason maybe that junkie
in the park will never touch a drug
again
also ending and that's beneath the room
are you kidding me with this bulb right
now holy
this movie is nearly three hours long oh
god why oh my lord auric the rock I got
a big old life blown away in the blink
of an eye
nothing left but all the time in the
world to think about it who's in the box
oh what's in the box
you're in grave danger you said he was
in danger I said grave danger if you
want to get a woman to fall in love with
you feed her poetry
remember no women no kids there has been
killing is that
[Music]